thanks for joining us on the program as
we continue to look at those pictures
part I mean it really brings everything
into shop Focus doesn't it um talk to me
about the strike though where are we
well I'm at St Mary's in Paddington
along with these brilliant nurses that
you see behind me standing out for
another day on picket lines losing a
day's pay and why because this
government and the Prime Minister Rishi
sunai has turned this back on these
nurses in fact if you look at what
happened across England and compared to
Scotland and Wales where both
governments have got to the table and
started to negotiate it can only be
described that the nurses in England now
are being punished have left behind by
Rishi sunag in this government
no I was reading over the weekend that
if there was an increase of potentially
another three percent in the offer from
the government that you would consider
that on behalf of your members that's
what been that's what's been offered to
nurses in Wales is that fair to say that
that's something that you would consider
if nursing has said all along that once
we get to a negotiating table and an
offer is put to our members we would
immediately call off any strikes because
that's the right thing to do for
patients and for the public and we will
consult with our members our members
will make that decision and they always
make the right decision as nurses so
that's what's happened in Wales and
that's what happened in Scotland but we
can't get that to happen in England
because this prime minister will not
come to a table and not speak for his
nurses on behalf of his nurses with me
um it was promised at the last nurses
strike that cancer treatment would be
unaffected by walkouts um NHS England
telling us that cancer appointments
including chemotherapy were disrupted
and rescheduled for some patients what
would you say
well look we have on this occasion made
the same safe decisions have been made
on the last days of strike nurses are
not Reckless they will not they will not
do anything Reckless they will not add
any or unsafe care that's not already
that they're trying to burden them or
battle with every day on behalf of their
patients so our exemptions this on this
occasion for the two days of strike have
remained the same we have ensured that
emergency and Urgent Care continues who
have ensured that cancer urgent Cancer
Treatments continue so that has not been
a decision by us to change to change our
exemptions for today and tomorrow I
understand that but your website saying
that chemotherapy should be completely
Untouched by strike action and the NHS
telling us Hospital in Lancashire
Hospital in London said that in fact a
nurse speaking on the condition of
anonymity saying that it was impacted
look we know that services and
treatments indeed including cancer
treatments are impacted day after day
within the Health Service there are many
harrowing stories of patients turning up
and finding that their chemotherapy has
been canceled simply because there
aren't enough nursing staff and medical
staff to treat them this is nothing new
what nurses are trying to do today is
stand out again once again to get this
prime minister to listen to them and say
please do the right thing for patience
do the right thing for the profession
let's address the 47 000 vegan nursing
hosts let's return the 35 000 nurses
that left last year in England alone and
he owes that to every single patient no
patient should be waiting on treatment
patients waiting on waiting lists year
after year 7 million plus that is no way
to treat the people of this country so
it is for the prime minister to make his
decisions get to your table now start to
negotiate choose choose talking over
striking that is is absolutely his
prerogative he needs to make that an
urgent decision today I'm available
today I'm available tonight I will talk
to him at any time of the day or night
to resolve this these nurses want to be
inside their hospitals not standing out
here in the cold losing another day's
pay it's no way to treat these nursing
staff because Before I Let You Go is
there any way that tomorrow's strike can
be averted
[Applause]
absolutely the strike can be averted by
Rishi sunai coming to a table and
talking to me now anytime between now
and tomorrow and putting an offer on the
table so that I can consult with these
nurses and make sure that they get the
they get a decent pay rise a decent a
decent outcome for them is a decent
outcome for patients okay we must leave
it there Pat um thanks for taking the
time